this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised
is why the inclement ride is such a firm
favorite
miss pinkie toe
it just looks ready for a fight this is
still her territory good afternoon and
welcome to another episode of a safari
lives it's fantastic to be archer in the
sabi sand and soo-ji is also art with me
driving around here and then of course
the fellows and the Mara bringt and as
well as David will be a scouting art for
all sorts of wonderful things today it's
erm well it's 29 degrees Celsius 89
degrees Fahrenheit in both locations so
the temperature is fair today it's
really really quite nice and I'm hoping
that it's going to mean that we're going
to have quite a bit of action earlier on
in the afternoon but let's get right
into it because this week has been a
very very busy week out yet in both the
Mara and the sabi sand and I'm excited
for to see what else happens this
afternoon all the Kruger action happened
on Zuma this week Kangana appeared a
treehouse damn to welcome Tyler back and
then disappeared his son was typically
busy hunting exploring and leading us on
a merry chase just about every day he
concentrated his efforts to the north
but returned to Juma pan to kill twice
Tandy and Columba made a brief
appearance in the far north and
disappeared again up in the Mara Kenya
made a very welcome appearance near the
Tanzanian border the North clan were
their typical hunting scavenging
fascinating selves
while the all Olalla pride with
wistfully to the south were the herds
are concentrating and short green grass
of the recent burns busy busy as I said
pretty incredible all the things that
we've seen it's fantastic to have Kenya
back after she disappeared that was
there a female cheetah that we all grew
quite a fond to and she also had some
cups a little while ago but sadly lost
them all and we think she disappeared
down into Tanzania but she's back again
so that's good news maybe brains will
catch up with her a little bit later the
other thing that we're going to be doing
I'll share this afternoon because
there's so much action happening here on
a Juma and the sabi sand is that I'm
gonna be searching for wild dogs and
that's exactly what I'm doing right now
as I'm just having a little scratch
around with our last left but it seems
as though they've given me the slip they
could have either gone down into the
drainage line or perhaps they've gone to
twin dams which is not too far away to
cool off after a hot day but we've had
some fantastic sightings of them the
adults have been well exceptionally good
parents and we're all very very happy to
have those bundles of joy on the
property the investor can barley break
away pack of dogs have been making their
rounds on Juma along with a six puppies
it's hard work being a wild dog puppy at
only three and a half months old trying
to keep up with the adults as they go
out in search for food when they are not
running around they find comfort and
playing with their litter mates
the adults have successfully killed
numerous times and regurgitated the
remains for the hungry youngsters with
Bailey's bursting at the seams the only
thing to do next is to flop down on the
floor and go to sleep
I still cannot stop smiling and I really
hope that we get another opportunity to
see them today but as most of you know
that I've ever been following the lives
of well just wild dogs in general but
now we can specifically focus on the in
Bambi Lee a invest tech breakaway pack
which is really quite exciting because
it's been a very long time since Where's
Waldo have seen a pack on a regular
basis now the reason we're going to be
seeing this pack for quite some time is
of course because of all the little
puppies they can't travel as far as the
adults can now remember because this is
a live and interactive Safari we
encourage questions submit to us them
hashtag a safari life and all of the
guides this afternoon look forward to
answering them for you perhaps it's your
first time watching if it is let us know
and we'll explain all the dynamics
between the animals
Pat's you're quite correct and saying
that this is a fun job because you can't
I don't know what to expect 100% it's
definitely one of the best jobs I've
ever had in a while I've been lucky even
you know guiding for cooking for for
quite some time but this specifically is
pretty unbelievable
but um I'm trying to think now where
have these wild dogs gone see that end
of our Traverse is just off to the right
so it's quite easy that they could have
popped off of the off of Jummah and onto
another property and maybe headed a
little bit further south towards sure to
a dam now that wouldn't surprise me at
all and Trust where damn there's a huge
body of what I mean obviously you can
see we're driving over the dam wall of
twin dams and I can just have a look and
see how the water is drying up and
there's a lot more water down to the
south with lots of animals around lots
of impaler lots of water back and all
sorts of other things so it's a stem
walk and a cat - which is what I think
the wild dogs are feeding on at the
moment
and specifically and the investor can
barley break away pack now there's only
four adults
so they've got a they've got a tough job
ahead of them while dog packs can get
quite big and but this is a small group
but let's keep our fingers crossed
that's those puppies and make it all the
way to adulthood they did started eight
puppies from from what I've read and
sadly we've already and lost two of them
but that's alright it's just one of
those things nature as harsh nature is
tough but there's still six around and
those adults are doing a good job but
somebody else that's been doing a
sterling job at hunting is husana and
while he's no stranger to all of you
because he's been around for the last
few weeks
I can see him down that Osama is busy
trying to feed this is one of the caucus
which has been hiding here for a while
now a very very good afternoon and
welcome to the beginning of the
afternoon show
I am Sydney humor and my cozy I am
traveling with VM this afternoon who is
my camera operator and we are going to
try by all means to give you the best
experience ever for your questions and
comments you can follow us on Twitter
hashtag safari live you can also follow
us on youtube chat stream my plan for
this afternoon is done already I have
got four asana with me at the moment
trying to get hold of something to eat I
think it must be very full at the moment
because he has been feeding since
yesterday and this feeding activities
started a day before yesterday he's just
moving from one tree to the other where
he's hiding
all these three different carcasses I
can see the stomach looks very much full
listen to that
so the jaws are very much strong and the
tooth are can be very much strong is
busy crashing all the bones from the
hips of this small data here in this day
has not smelling nice at the moment
because it was kept here for quite a
while
James no that is true indeed Juma has
been an action-packed for this week a
lot of activities are happening here
specifically there predation activities
savasana was very lucky for not getting
any disturbances from any other leopards
in the area for the past couple of days
this morning we were very lucky with
king Ghana who also got his own meal on
the other side which is not very far
away from here the only one I haven't
seen for a while is Tandy and Caramba
maybe they also got something somewhere
oh look at that he nearly dropped the
caucus so you can see that he's busy
trying to take off all the hair stays
cleaning all the hair so that he can eat
nicely he doesn't want to feed on those
ass is trying to get rid of the hairs
before he swallows them but if he does
that if he does feed on those hairs by
any mistake he's got a way of getting
rid of those kind of s from the stomach
so the cats are very well designed and
well gifted
so now let's go to the Masai Mara where
my other colleague David has got some
zebra crossing I don't think it's a road
sign
what is he having as a real zebra
crossing everybody and welcome to our
Sunset Drive all the way from the Amara
triangle in Kenya and I have respected
husana for what he does in terms of
hunting but once in a while leopards are
also been known to go for zebras and we
got a huge herd of zebras here and what
we might see or who might eat them today
is not Hasaan of the leopard but maybe
croc rus' we've been sitting just next
to the murray over the last two hours
waiting for these animals to cross the
river my name is David and money the
camera is Manu
good after Manu are you feeling the
things the Sun was going across
Morrisville convinced the zebras will
cross and remember this is a very
interactive show will request you to
send through your questions or any
comments you may have on hashtag Safari
like and you can keep following us a
YouTube chat stream now the big decision
yet to be made is who is going to cruise
the river fast at the moment you can
tell the bid thirsty and what they need
to do is to quench their thirst then an
important decision has to be made who
will commit himself over so fast to come
across this river that is infested by
crocodiles migration or crossing of the
Muriwai is always done by either zebras
or will beasts but we currently have
ZBrush
while painter don't you asking observer
US have a breeding season I would say
zebra sir do not have a breeding season
especially here in Kenya or in the Mara
Triangle unlike their friends the
wildebeest who have a very special very
particular breeding season so I'm sure
you're enjoying that video of those
zebras drinking water but zebras do not
have breeding season and they'll have
curves or round they are the other
animals of the species they'll always
migratory the wildebeest have a very
marked or defined breeding season and
every month of February the first week
or the second week of area they'll go to
a country code Tanzania and eastern side
of the Serengeti National Park or the
Western and Gordon got a conservation
area they'll always drop their young
ones there every February but the Zebras
do not have breeding season what a
beautiful sight that is I think there's
a picture to take and just frame it not
sure in your kitchen or in your sitting
room just to be seen that every day I
will not be surprised if there's a lot
of pressure building from the back and
the drinking might stop and they'll
decide to cross
meaning lots of happiness to hear your
name I'll tell you the migration this
year came rather late we were a bit
worried what was happening but we know
for all the years personally I have been
in the bush the migration has never
failed to come to the Mara from
Serengeti so it's a bit late or which
came in it obvious who got a feeling it
too might stay with us a little bit
longer before they start heading south
again to Serengeti we've been sitting
here for the last two hours or so and
our keyword here with Manu is patience
and without patience we can do much just
have to be patient and just keep waiting
hoping that these zebras are going to
cross the Mara River so the river you
see there on your screen is called the
Mara River it's quite long about 400
kilometres long or about 250 miles long
it's originates in some place in the
root of all in Kenya an area called the
Maoist cup meant and it drains on the
mouth of the Lake Victoria which is the
second largest freshwater lake in the
world after Lake Superior in America but
in Africa Lake Victoria is the largest
freshwater lake we got and apparently
that's the source of the Nile River not
sure this zebras know the water the
drinking if you drop a you know a drop
of water here and give it a dye this
water will flow all the way to Lake
Victoria all the way to the Nile River
and it will drain finally at the
meditation sea
so we just need a lot of confidence we
need one leader here who will take the
risk and go across the water and then
the rest will follow soon now from a
small hobby forum let's go over to South
Africa and see a big hot vote with
Sydney you can see now that there is
quite a lot of dust coming towards my
direction there now as the biggest head
of the Buffaloes is busy now approaching
the via Telepan this is quite a very big
head is the second time I'm seeing this
head not long time ago I was on a guided
walk and I saw them but when I'm looking
at them I think now is more than the
last time look at that some of the big
ones are also far at the back oh there's
even some of the little ones here
together with a their mothers this is a
very big breeding head and this kind of
head is the ones that mostly attract the
big predators such as the Lions to come
and visit us very often so this morning
I I did pick up an audio of a lion roar
coming from the middle of the reserve
I'm not too sure if maybe it was the
Avoca mares
you can see that now the buffalos are
drinking and at the same time the oak
speakers are doing their job quite a lot
of oxpeckers right on top of these
buffaloes well they're also hitching a
lift you can see that the oxpeckers they
got quite a lot of numerous benefits
from these buffaloes it's not only about
getting the ticks but also and tired I'm
sure for a distance they can also get
some assistance they are catching a lift
look at that so these bears can be able
to reach the areas where the animals
themselves cannot be able to get rid of
the chicks polar the Buffaloes they do
swim I can see one is in the middle now
trying to have a swim it's just that is
height and you can see just a small
portion of so the buffaloes they do swim
but let me rather say they don't swim
they just go and lie in water so they'll
act to entertain the mud wallows when
they're at the mud wallows you will see
them rolling rolling there to try and
datafile themselves just to cover the
body with mud they like to do that
you can see that this head is too big
layer covering that hole via Telepan
look at that look at that one trying to
clean some of the parasite from the eyes
look at that so now let's go back to
Taylor who got some interesting highness
we do indeed laying underneath that
Amber tea tree when all the shadows cast
down on it is a hyena
I wonder what on earth this hyena is
doing now we've been looking for a wild
dogs but I forgot to tell you that
there's somebody else I was looking for
and that is the ultimate King the
reigning male leopard by the name of
King Ghana and I haven't seen him for a
little while but I did see him a few
days ago a waterhole patrol turned into
something more sin Ghana was resting up
in the shade at tree house damn it
wasn't long before he showed signs of
waking up and a drink was in order to
quench his thirst on a hot afternoon
with a round belly it was evident that
in Ghana had found himself a small meal
which explained why we hadn't seen him
recently but he soon announced his
return to all the underlayment pretty
fantastic stuff it was an amazing
welcome back to see it in Ghana now I
have to tell you a really funny story
because st. when I followed him I mean
like I said what a welcome back it was
he drank a treehouse down which is just
behind us actually a little bit north
west from where we are now just a few
hundred meters not far at all and we try
to follow him along the drainage line so
now this is after we lost him and it was
pretty incredible for those of you who
are watching a little daycare actually
ran out with mom and Cheng Anna had no
idea that they were there and he tried
to chase them but then we lost him it
was getting dark we thought we'd better
not follow him guess what happened later
on that evening look what's up in the
top of the tree now it's quite gruesome
it is an Impala and that has been hung
in there treat a bite in Ghana now he's
been hiding away here for the last
couple of days and we didn't even know
because he's right in the middle of the
strange land and it was it's quite thick
still even with all the leaves haven't
have fallen off of the tree so quite
interesting he's obviously been feeding
on that for for quite some time but now
he's moved on there's nothing left of
that kill so as you can imagine I don't
know where he's gone I'm gonna suspect
that he's maybe gone for one final drink
of water I think that that could be the
case what do you think Sansa do you
think he's gone forward and we have
heard a little bird alarming too and the
fact that this hyena is here now I think
it's probably annoyed ting Ghana
slightly so he's just said right I'm
done with his carcass I've fed on it for
a few days I managed to give all the
people the slip it's time to move on and
he's not afraid to move around during
the day she just clearly saw now if you
don't know hooting Ghana is perhaps it
is your first time watching and he is
the resident male leopard around here he
is the most dominant one in the sector
on Juma he pops into before shock every
now and then which is a property just
north of us he extends into tortured he
pops under Chitra we were talking about
that early where all the water is and
then he goes a little bit further south
and west and around here and then he has
another male leopard by the name of
hooker mori and then also the Anderson
Mail which are kind of just on the
outskirts of his territory so any paths
he's also gone on a bit of a walkabout
it isn't hot in comparison to the last
few days that we had so I think from
here let's go back and start checking
the watering halls again ah there we go
Durga speaking of hookah mori and
mentioning him and I haven't seen him
for ages however he was sighted briefly
because maybe you remember a couple of
days ago there was a pride of lions by
the name of Inka Houmas and we might get
a chance to see them because and they
apparently won the move this morning so
we might go check Church work for them
truth we don't have any luck yet
but he was on a kill a trade damn
witches on arrow Sousa which is a
property just to the west of us and
thinking rumors came on around and going
for a drink after they'd made a kill and
devoured it here on on Juma and chased
him off of his kill and they took it for
themselves so who Comorian came charging
on into Germany only Spain's a little
while here but from what I can
understand it sounds like he's somewhere
between Aerith user an elephant plane so
much for the waste of us he hasn't been
spending much time here I think King
Ghana has made himself very clear that
he is the dominant male and he ought to
be respected right it seems as though
David is having fantastic laugh like
this afternoon he's at the river's edge
the zebra look like they want across to
sit in Ghana but ladies and gentlemen a
very warm welcome back to the Masai Mara
triangle and we are seeing what have
been waiting for for the last two and a
half hours and those it was just
crossing the Mara River and if you look
carefully on the left there's a
crocodile very well done Manu we have
been waiting here crossing fingers and
hoping something gonna happen but
there's a crocodile is very very close
to the zebras there and hopefully he
oh she's flange get hold of one of them
how epic how exciting this is this is
what everybody in the world want to see
there's a croc there
he's just calculating and waiting to see
who will go for the zebra struggling and
then he calls the clock he just missed
and Lou in the front of control how
amazing is that there's a crocodile
there miss Sumi and straight to get hold
of one there he goes the crocker is
trying to get all of one oh my goodness
one zebra down how many to go if you
look carefully there's a croc there
there it's trying to get one down and
what they do they do what is called a
death roll just get one and just spin it
in the water and try and suffocate them
I don't know what might have happened
there whether she got it or not in the
meantime they continue crossing and you
can tell how an even the base of the
river is is full of rocks there's
another zero they're just going some of
the edge of the water Sam's drinking or
keep going yeah it's got it it got it
it's got the hind quarters unfortunately
or fortunately and doing the final
control says Wow and I would like to
warn anybody who is a bit screamish
maybe not to watch this you might maybe
switch off your screen or have a walk
and come back later but this is nature
as it should be I'm not sure who to feel
sorry for the zebra or to celebrate for
the crocodile I will leave that your own
judgment and again as I said if your
best scrimmage please do not watch this
but this is how things go out here in
the world
so the croc just managed to catch that
one zebra and just pushing it to the
back and it will get it most likely to
the bank and the rest keep crossing and
I think there could be another one there
there's another croc that's holding that
by the neck so this is two zebras and
two Crocs so two zebras down and many to
go how big is this this is how it goes
and now this lioness coming in very well
done Manu now we might be seeing
something out of the owner here
oh my gosh oh my goodness and Lewis in
the final control says oh no this is
exactly how mother nature walks
so the lioness will go very close to the
zebras and chance to see if she'll be
able also to be lucky like the Crocs so
she just sits there she has to be sure
unlike the coconuts that are in the
water and they're granted that's the
path that all the zebras are going to
check the lioness risks being spotted by
this zebras how epic is this oh my
goodness there could be a third one
they're not sure this is a very fast one
we saw but definitely in this particular
zebra nose it's done she's not even
moving
and unfortunately the Zebras are not
doing much to hurt her kha'zix I'll tell
you it's quite unfortunate what should
happen is I think this particular zebra
is already traumatized and because she
has traumatized she cannot do much what
I would imagine if this were human
beings would come and help this other
one here but I think she's just quit
traumatized as there you know she's
given her chest a look at the latest
give me the chest
she's running she's running she's
running giving the chest there now see
how lucky she is she's running there go
the two lionesses they don't want came
from had seen one before and they all
missed this is turning out to be very
dramatic how epic is this this is insane
oh my goodness we have all types of
predators here and I think the only
winning or success predators here are
the Crocs and the hippos just watching
on the side and that is zero you see
there the belly
I think it's case is done and the Crocs
are left they're just moving closer the
Iona says oh you wanna try again then
she goes there she goes she's running
she's give another chance just give it
another
she's give another chance there she goes
there she goes Justin that is one of the
best words I've had today of pandemonium
that's a very good Justin it is exactly
pandemonium
we got Crocs on one side zebras on the
other side lay on someone the other side
and my exaggerated share with Manuel yes
Justin this is nothing but pandemonium
please remember to send your questions
through any comments you may have like
party like Justin who say this a
pandemonium we are very much welcome I'm
not sure you can hear in the background
there the hippos going not sure the
celebrating or the cheering the crops or
the zebras I do not know what that means
but maybe the hippos want the Lions know
of their presence and unfortunately the
planning of the lioness they are not
sure about that unfortunately
unfortunately was not very good
and this has interrupted the crossing of
the zebras and you can tell she is not
dead yet Lauren do hippos eat crocodiles
crocodiles are carnivores Rosaline and
he pulls a hobby boss so if anything
oops little fight between the two did
that call didn't let go if it let go
then I had a question idea of whether
the zippered croc all allowed crack the
skull of a crocodile but the Zebras
trying to bite the the Cocker at the
same time so two more covers are coming
in to give a hand to the one that is
holding the hindquarters of oh la la my
goodness this is an epic battle here I
might be calling this the bat of the
Maasai Mara and you can see the blood in
the flash coming out there again it
requests anybody who is creamish please
not watch this you can have a little
walk and maybe come back later began as
I said this is Mother Nature and this is
how things go here so what the
crocodiles will try to do is to is to
suffocate this zebra and just make sure
it gets in the water and yes Alou in the
final control says this croc is massive
some of his cobblers are about 20 feet
long huge massive reptiles and as soon
as it's drums it's not going to be able
to breathe and that's where it's gonna
die let's think that's what the Crockers
want to do and like lions which have
known or lib or other catholic developer
to suffocate or to hold to the mouths of
the zebra the crops may not be able to
do that just like ours and maybe they
have to wait until maybe she drowns and
she can't breathe anymore
well this is taking too long to have her
die if she has to die I would be happy
if she died quickly unfortunately to say
that but we don't have we don't want her
to be such pain for so long
Luisi I do not know what to say my heart
beats I guess if nothing has changed
about 72 times to a minute but I was
telling my I think now I'm doing that
I'm being double that I could be doing
close to a hundred and fifty and my
adrenaline has gone very high and you
can tell who is he the croc have started
to enjoy it his sweat not sure what part
of the zebra it's eating and how epic
this has been quite dramatic and as
Justin said this is such a pond ammonium
well chances are the Zebras will start
doing what they're doing before before
the Lions came in and interrupted the
crossing and they have to get to the
other side I'm sure I'm not going to get
a question of hawai at the zebras going
or why the zebras crossing the river
knowing how dangerous it is but part of
the migration this is part of it and
this is zebra is not letting go and it's
not ready to die it's still trying to
fight back as they say the last kicks of
a dying horse
apparently zebras and horses and the
same family and sure enough these
crocodiles should do a better job I do
not want this zebra to be in such pain
for so long oh my goodness
the only thing they do crocodiles have
been known not to be able to cut they
don't have the rights teeth to cut and
he flashes they only pull and swallow
and that's why it's got to challenge
them for here to just maybe do a quick
walk on this zebra and getting a dying
she is still kicking not gone yet
remember you can tweet your questions
hashtag safari live any comments you may
have it's very welcome and this is quite
dramatic is something I have not seen in
a very very long time in all my years in
the bush
well as Justin says this is such a
pandemonium he's slowly dying down and
I'm sure the Zebras will be thinking do
they take a chance and cross again and
risk their life and because they have to
do it they may do it and now from
predators the crocodiles as we have been
having here on the Mara River let's go
close to South African find out what
Hosanna as a predator is up to wow that
sounds like a lovely sighting of the
crocodiles in the Zebras and the Lions
by the Mara it sounds like it has been
an interesting activities taking place
there but I'm here now you can see a
story I've got Hosanna who is trying to
finish up the Dacre now he's only left
with a small piece and this Dekker is
not smelling nice look at that he's also
tired I think he is eating too much for
the past two or three days he's just
been eating and eating eating after
eating every day the stomach looks so
big to me this is very full
so now we are going to watch the video
that has been taken when hasana was
trying to conduct some hunting
activities during the week the rapid
movement of the years ahead and tail
showed that the young male leopard
husana affectionately known as the
little chief was concentrating with
great in terms the movement of the prey
animal behind the bushes confirmed that
it was small antelope a dega who was
under serious scrutiny astana smooth
walk and crossing front legs showed his
desire to remain hidden from the data
and this skillful spotted cat spoiled
the chances of catching the prey
due to his youthful impatience life in
the bush is never easy the unsuccessful
hunting activities of husana we took
place during the week has just confirmed
that I honestly have got to improve his
hunting activities because he's so
getting impatient and this kind of cats
remember they've got to learn a lot but
for them to be well experienced and to
have a good knowledge when it comes to
hunting activities they can only obtain
it after a two years so now let's go to
Taylor who's got a lovely taker
approaching Tanana look at this look at
the little Baker it's a very small
antelope this looks like a very young
one and I'm small but it doesn't look
like an adult can you see how suspicious
it's acting at the moment that's because
we finally managed to find ting gana the
king of Juma the male leopard that we
were talking about there he sits but he
has absolutely no idea that that Dacre
is I kid you not
hey guys the day canna I'm just trying
to think exactly he must only be about
15
feet away from thing garnet I mean it's
really close not close enough that he
could get up and run towards it the dake
is gonna have the upper hand and the
problem nas and I don't know if they're
Dacres realize what ting Ghana is
because it hasn't run away it does
actually come back the second time now
this is unbelievable
so it is young it is an experience it is
probably very curious perhaps mama's
just left that little one but now Fort
in Ghana there's a bird party that's
moving on through you can hear them all
calling and they're most certainly going
to start alarming at the fact that
there's a big male leopard laying down
on the ground
and maybe that'll be the helping hand
that that looking Baker needs it seems
to be very uncertain so hopefully if
they come through remember all the
animals are chair they can speak the
same language even though we don't
understand it most of the time and that
little one should know exactly what's
going on it's the I son ran away it's
actually coming out in the open now that
Dec I don't know if you can see it
basically just in between that log and
there tree there it is just to the right
can see look it's really small probably
only a few months old I don't think it
can smelt in Ghana very well - oh you
better be very careful luckily for the
stake I think in Ghana's old age his
about twelve years old now I think it's
getting to him perhaps ease his hearings
going because I even heard that little
Baker rustling around in the grass and
all the timber tea leaves that are on
the ground be very careful you're very
inquisitive nose is going to get you
into a lot of trouble little daycare
Oh Richard a great question from you
about Singhania and the reason why he's
painting so much it's quite hot today so
that's just one of the reasons the fact
that it is quite warm and he's also got
a full belly because he stuffed himself
full full of Impala so often when they
gorge in gorge themselves with whatever
they may have eaten it puts a lot of
strain on their diaphragm and it
basically is folding about so much that
he can't take these these long deep
breaths anymore he's got to do the short
stuff but the panting of course helps
cool him down so it's a combination of
two you know what you feel like after
you've eaten yourself you almost feel
sick and you get quite hot you must get
a hot flash I don't think he feels sick
but I think he's probably quite warm so
he's just trying to keep out of the
shade now even though he is full he's
always looking for his next meal and
like I said that Impala is finished is
really just the neck just left I don't
think he'll go back for something like
that I think this evening he'll probably
move on do a bit of a territorial patrol
go have a drink of water and start
looking for dinner Laurie no a leopard
does not roll when it makes em a Kilner
the term we actually used to describe
the Sun that a leopard makes when it
does a territorial call as a saw and
then we hear them growling but they
don't draw like a lion's a lion wouldn't
necessarily raw either after making a
kill and for example if a leopard were
to celebrate that it had successfully
killed something can you imagine all the
lions and hyenas and potentially other
leopards in the area that would come
racing on and to go I'd like a piece of
that pie thank you very much and so
they'll probably try and keep quite
quiet about it and also hope that when
they do take on their prey and they have
made a kill that the prey hasn't given
off to me distress calls because again
that's gonna bring in the hyenas and the
hyenas are everywhere at the moment they
are all around but I'm glad to see ting
honor and that he is quite full
because if you have been following his
story over the last couple years you
would have known that a couple of months
ago at the beginning of the year he was
quite ill he was quite sick and we were
really concerned we're really worried
that we were going to lose him we
thought his reign was over and we were
talking about hooker Morey who is a new
male leopard to the sabe sandal to this
area in the north we thought he was
going to come on in and take over his
territory but he came back fighting
though which is fantastic to see and
here he sits as dominant as ever
I'm so sorry Nicky please can you repeat
that question again I didn't there's a
part I'm missing and in here ah sorry
beau Nick and you know I think it's
quite difficult to say what senses go
first with the older leopards just
speaking about in Ghana and he is quite
old for a for a male leopard I mean he's
in he's he's past his prime years now
so theoretically you should only have
about another year or so and it you know
to be as powerful as what he's going to
be but he is getting old and when he
gets injured it's gonna take him longer
and longer to recover as it does with
humans so I don't know if it's their
eyesight that goes first or their
hearing or a combination of both but I'm
pretty sure as they get older that their
senses aren't as acute as what they were
when they were a youngster but he still
listens out of course perhaps he's
panting so loudly it's drowning out the
sound of that little Baker that was
sneaking around it's still sneaking
around it hasn't gone anyway and like I
said when when I to stop talking I can
hear it moving about every now and then
areas just back there you can't just
seize legs underneath that fallen log
there he goes wonderful news take her he
really be careful well where am I
certainly not going to go anywhere we're
gonna hopefully see what happens let's
go say hello to Brent
[Music]
I've never seen in my life it is one of
the most endangered birds in Africa I'm
not going to tell you what it is just
yet where we have been seeing Kenya for
the last while is the road I was looking
for so let's go see what Kenya got up to
a few days ago we found - Kenya scanning
the open plains of the central Mara
Triangle
she moved from termite mound to termite
mound searching for potential prey she
spotted alone
Subodh el Tommy amongst the rocks but
unfortunately for Kenya the Tommy was
aware and spotted her before she could
get close enough luckily for her shortly
after her misadventure with a sub-adult
tummy she flushed a baby Thomson's
gazelle and after a quick chase she
caught the unfortunate youngster proving
that a baby Tommy a day keeps the hunger
at bay hello welcome back wasn't that
incredible that happened actually just
in this area probably about less than a
kilometre from where I am now but you
can see there's a very big fire on the
other side of the river that's causing
all this haze around us this evening now
there are some big herds of wildebeest
around
and while we are looking for our
feathered friend bounce bounce we
definitely might miss the road these
rates haven't been driven often yes it
is the right
we definitely might or is it not a road
it's not right it is already rejected we
might find Kenya as well see with this
fire these roads have become quite
difficult to spot for this lovely green
flash and who grass the same height it's
more difficult to see the tracks of the
ride now remember we are 100% live so
I'm bouncing my poor cameraman and
Ranger across this area now to try find
this very very rare bird
I'm very very excited it's the right guy
here's the road I think this is the road
yes this is the road it was the road at
some point in its life there are
somewhere out in this big burnt area
they've been following members of the
happy zebra hyena clan what what was
that sorry go again
I've lost the road again there it is
lots of cases that it's an Egyptian
vulture I have completely lost the right
just with the red garden
there's no right it's just disappeared
huh the right is good we're just gonna
go straight I have permission from
justice to go straight we did start on a
red we didn't intentionally now drive
through the bush but we have a lot of
guesses it's an Egyptian vulture that is
all this from big holes yeah that is a
very good guess but I'm not going to
tell you what it is just yet I don't
want to follow a vulgar beast part so
while I follow a bull to be spot let's
send you back to the little prince of
the sabi sands you can see now that AO
sana is slowly more boiling towards that
direction so I'm not sure if maybe he's
heading towards the waterhole now you're
Telepan or not but by the other side
where the water is the Buffaloes are
still around there so I don't think you
take that chance of going there while
the Buffaloes are still having that time
so I am just going to now keep following
and see where he is going
he slowly mobile in towards the area way
the
hello and over as Steve our solder
managed to get hold of about three
different kills he caught a de coeur and
after a daycare he caught a small Yala
and after his Manya I caught another
taker so he has been just eating for the
past few days so you can see the stomach
is very fooled now oh it's changing
directions now instead of going to the
water hole he is now moving much more up
going back to that study so relaxed now
under a nice shade so I'm just gonna
tend so that he can have a better visual
cuz where I am is not easy for me to see
him again
for now we can watch or Sun up in a tree
trying to have his takeoff this is a
sighting that took place
few days ago it looked like it had been
a very long day for the little chief or
Sun yearning body scratching and stiff
walking is what led us to the most after
long periods of daily rest leopards are
the only cats would climb trees
regularly over here and they make it
look so easy
their bodies are perfectly designed for
the tree climbing their back legs very
powerful help to prepare them while
their balance is also excellent asana
prefers to hide food high up in big
trees to avoid competition from other
species such as hyenas so that was a
very interesting exciting to see Xhosa
are trying to have something from high
up by the marula tree so if he doesn't
do that he knows very well that on the
ground here is quite a lot of
competitions we do have a lot of ideas
that are roaming around waiting for a
chance so he was very lucky to take
something up to a tree and where we have
just seen him now feeding on that caucus
is not far away from where he has been
hiding some other carcasses but looking
at the tummy now you can see that he has
been consuming quite a lot of food this
cat has been feeding non-stop for the
past three days and he managed to get a
hold of three different Decker's in less
than 24 hours
congratulations - or sauna for that as
he battled a lot before getting those
kind of nurse
maybe he's listening to me when I am
giving him such positive commands so I
don't know how much time he's going to
take before the next hunt because I can
see even if something comes here nearby
I don't think because of this wait it
will be able to chase an animal
Safari Solly and Astana is not worried
about our presence at all because he
still having a normal natural human fear
so when he's here now he knows that we
are not a threat that if I try to get
off the ground now what is going to do
now is that he will leave me alone and
just move away
now is the time for him to rest I think
is fair enough for him to rest now
because he is full and lucky that is not
far away from the water or look at that
the rate of breathing you can see that
he is full you can even see how the
stomach is pumping a day
Rosina host alum esse catch normally
they reached maturity when they're over
two years but to start breeding
they must have to wait until they're
four years because four years is when
the level of testosterone is high for
them to to turn to become aggressive so
that they can be able to defend the
territories and that is what gives them
an access to mate with the females but
at this stage I don't think asana is
ready yet to challenge the other big
mares to impress the females for mating
activities so cats they have got to do
something in order to impress the
females cause females are interested on
those that has got very strong strengths
so that that is going to give their
little ones better genes oh you can see
now the we have got a very big head of
the Buffalo is also feeding not very far
away from where we are we got two
different sightings of the big five
animals from the same spot but now let's
go back to my colleague let's go back to
Taylor who is searching for something
I'm not too sure now what he lays up to
we found what we've been searching for
though since all let me fix that for you
cuz he keeps turning his head I'm just
gonna go forward just a little bit sorry
everyone
bear with us for two seconds there's
lots of sticks we trying to avoid that
better trying to avoid ending Ghana has
perfectly placed himself in between all
the twigs and branches anyways so the
little dagger has decided that ting
Ghana is not a friend to play with and
trotted officers should have otherwise
it would have found itself inside
Dingaan is Bailey which I don't think it
would have appreciated but he's still
just sitting up and around he's panting
heavy oh he's just doing a big yawn
that's exciting that's typically a sign
that he might be waking up and the fact
that he has been sitting up for quite
some time I'm hoping that he does ji-sun
goes for a drink he's got two options
treehouse
or twin dams they're both of equal
distance I'd say now there was a bit of
drama that happened during the week not
with a 10 Ghana
however husana who you've been watching
with Sydney had a bit of an altercation
with Tandy it was evident that husana
had picked up on a saint in the distance
he followed his nose which took him to
Tandy she was displeased to see her
brother and immediately ran at him
engaging in a physical swallow it soon
became clear that sandy had made a kill
and imparted you to be precise husana
helped himself to the impart er but it
wasn't long before hyena came charging
in husana made a run for it with the
stolen Impala and attempted to seemed a
tree he failed as the hyena launched
itself into the air and grabbed his tail
hasanah
immediately dropped the kill unimpressed
with a hyenas tenacity
the young prince the tickets are still
back what he had stolen from tiny but
the hyenas are witted and are playing
this time wasn't that absolutely
fascinating now of course that could
happen at any moment because there was a
hyena hanging around here and and
there's also a kill
although ting gana was very clever this
time and like his son husana and took
his kill up a tree before anybody could
get to him unfortunately hyenas cannot
climb vertical trees although I've seen
them you know attempt to when the
branches are slightly more horizontal
and closer down to the ground up and
down he goes but pretty spectacular and
husana was really lucky there that is
the first time I've actually ever seen
him be so brave where he's been willing
to take on tündi like that and also kept
revving that hyena which was impressive
not Tyra
a leopard like a 10 ghana who's in the
prime of his life he's got a full belly
he's got lots of muscle and he's just in
fantastic condition I would say that he
is between 80 and 90 kilograms or so so
it's a big cats and fooled with just
absolute power
I don't think husana is anywhere near
there I think he's probably around maybe
60 kilograms or so maybe even slightly
less maybe between 50 and 60 kilograms
or perhaps I'm being a bit shy on my
numbers there Hasan is also not a small
cat I would like to see 10 Ghana and
husana next to one another and and and
that wouldn't be impossible because
we've had some phenomenal sightings an
unusual interaction between father and
son and I've been lucky enough to be a
witness to that I mean a couple of
months ago we were down at chitwa chitwa
where 10 Ghana was recovering from
whatever injury it may have been we
suspected all the few people suspected
it was a snake bite but it's very
difficult to confirm that anyways he was
there recovering one afternoon
we heard some squirrels and birds
alarming and we turned our heads away
from Singh Ghana who is just resting up
in the shade and a drainage I'm very
much like what we're witnessing today
and of course who came strolling on in
husana looking up at the trees and once
he realized
what we were looking at he went oh hello
dad and came down to say hello ting
Ghana was not impressed he growled a
little bit and they both snarled at one
another and but then wasana sort of sat
down I think he actually um even
urinated right in front almost on top of
his dad's head which I don't think Jen
garner would have taken to and to life
oh I don't he was impressed by it at all
but anyways he was too
he was too weak and couldn't be bothered
wasting and what little energy and
strength he had on a chasing Jorge
Hosanna
every Hosanna grew bored as dad was not
giving them the reaction or the
attention that he required so he carried
on with his day which was pretty cool to
see things like that it's the first time
for me that I've seen father and son
interacting and it's amazing to see how
ting gana is so tolerant of having
husana around because he goes about he
st. marks I haven't heard hassanis saw
yet
I think the moment husana becomes vocal
he's gonna find himself in a bit of
trouble I think that might be waiting
Ghana draws the line and says right
enough is enough because he doesn't have
that right to advertise like that he can
see st. Mark's often again as an insult
to sin Ghana but he sort of just puts up
with it now it sounds like there's just
action all over the show brain is racing
to you as secrets I think David has
witnessed an incredible spectacle
unfolding let's go see what else is
happening
it's our two other predators here who
have kept us almost breathless and our
heartbeats have gone high and the
crocodiles have been having a party I've
counted three zebras down and I'm sure
for the next few months now oh the
zebras or rather or the Crocs I will
know they have a lot to eat this croc
moving between the hippos there I don't
know how she's so fast not sure where
she's going and there has been a pond
ammonium here the last 45 minutes
Crocs lions
hippos zebras our heartbeats and Manu
going high and total excitement and
again for those for joining us for the
first time we are in Kenya and this is
the Mara River in the Mara triangle and
those are big reptiles that we call
crocodiles which could be related to
their alligators we have been very lucky
to see a migration or zebras crossing
the river do Roscoe the river is not
very deep I would say it arranges it has
an average depth of about a metre to two
meters maybe the deepest part could be
three meters Rosco I'm sure you saw that
croc that was holed a chunk of flesh in
this mouth from the three zebras that
they brought down and you can see their
zebras or rather crocodiles are not able
to chew and they just luckily cut meat
in big chunks and then they swallow it's
quite a long river about 400 kilometers
or about 250 miles long starting at some
highlands of Kenya going all the way to
or draining to Lake Victoria pretty
heavy current at the moment but the
Zebras were not would worried by that
and the place they chose to cross was
infested with lots of crocodiles and
these are what you call the Nile
crocodiles some of the largest reptiles
you got in the world
and it has been action parks for anybody
who might have missed you can always go
to youtube and watch what we were
watching before and I said anybody who
is a bit squeamish those about killing
and a bit of blood going on and sorry
about all the vehicles on the other side
of the river but they are also equally
enjoying this sighting just like me and
Manu and who could two lionesses here
now these are the two lionesses I was
talking about
not very lucky like the crocodiles on
three attempts they tried to make an
ambush and they did not perform very
well there were about 500 to 800 zebras
in total and I would say only 300
crossed the rest were not able to cross
and of all those were crossing the
lionesses were not likely to get any of
them so what would happen is the moment
they think of they sense a crossing
points dangerous the Zebras will try to
look for another crossing point which
could be massive and I think that's
where those zebras are going and my
brother Brad aha our feathered friend
with him now you don't get more exciting
for this this is more exciting than
lions leopards and even wild dogs one of
the rarest birds in Africa it is a
juvenile Egyptian vulture and this is my
first ever sighting of an Egyptian
vulture they are very very seldom seen
in the Mara mostly they prefer slightly
more arid areas so they've seen it in
the eastern Serengeti more than the
Western and there are very very few
breeding populations left they do occur
into Western Europe and down into
northwestern India Canary Islands Cape
Verde Islands the sahil the Sahara but
they're had their population has been
dwindling since the 1800s for lots of
different reasons mostly because of
better sort of sanitation around human
habitation they've got very very small
bills and they used to pick up lots of
different little bits of food where
people were messy and major competition
for them believe it or not which is why
that a lot of their their food sources
the domestic pigs and domestic dogs now
I'm gonna try sneak a little bit closer
I just wanted to make sure we saw it
first okay
this for me is their highlight of over a
year and a half in Kenya this bed number
one sighting okay we're gonna go into
low range for this sneaky sneaky sneaky
please don't fly don't fly down fly
don't fly don't fly don't fly don't fly
and if you do I'm ready
[Laughter]
it's teasing me okay I just watched see
if it lands again I'll try sneak a bit
closer now I'll trusty Hubert's but
closer shortly it's going to join with a
white back vote yet but I'll show you
what an adult looks like maybe get the
Egyptian vulture oh okay we're gonna go
sneaking again now another one of the
thing that's that's in southern Africa
that they were completely persecuted for
is the ability to open egg shells
particularly ostrich egg shells and they
were persecuted by farmers they were
actually shot with shotguns and so how
they they will use to open ostrich egg
shells that actually go grab a rock and
then fly high above the the nest and
drop the rock into the nest to to break
open the eggs
okay this is very very exciting
unfortunates not being very photographic
at all photogenic quite nervous it's a
very young bird and normally the
juveniles and sub adults that are seen
in the Mara are but older than this one
so I got sent a picture by the Michigan
State University ladies
looked like he was gonna fly again we'll
just have another safety you just jumped
right up to the top of the tree and
other thing so I they sent me a picture
I think I think I'm looking at a
juvenile Egyptian vulture and I was like
where are you I'm coming send me a
picture now and when they did I was like
yes you are
don't move I'm on my way and then it
flew off then they've been following it
till I got check cuz I was quite a long
way away
you guys you can see it quite nicely
James was asking how long does it get to
get adult plumage normally by about five
five years butts in certain indications
like that the the crest and stuff like
that
their little sort of poom the back of
the crown rough and sometimes certain
individuals take seven to eight years to
get that they live for about twenty
years in the wild or probably fifteen to
twenty years in the wild in captivity
the oldest record is about 23 years now
the most jealous person in the world
today is going to be Tristan so trusted
and I have spoken about abandoning work
when a juvenile Egyptian vulture has
been seen in Kruger and just going to
guys see this this see the juvenile
Egyptian vulture but unfortunately I
wish Tristan was here with me today he
would have left lions
to come and look at the Egyptian vulture
as well the Lions were sleeping but
getting a little bit closer now
so this is a massive bird on everyone's
list so I'm very excited that we got to
share it with you and now it's being a
little bit more forthcoming
so Paula is wondering how often do they
lay eggs pull it there's so little known
about their breeding that in in Africa
we're not really really sure and so
there are monogamous and they'll use the
same less nest for four years and in
theory they would lay every year and
during August to November is when
they'll be on the nest and it's it's and
that in Europe they've known that the it
takes 42 days for the babies to to hatch
in Africa they're so rare in Africa we
don't have exact information on on on on
how long it takes them to fledge and
stuff and also in areas where they've
been persecuted and there's been a lack
of food you often have egg failure so
they haven't been able to eat enough
calcium to for the eggs to be strong
enough for them to hatch that's one one
of the big problems with a lot of that
the predatory birds you can see the
smoke giving us quite an eerie eerie
sort of evening here in the Mara and
that is very exciting I mean we've
probably done 30 kilo 5 30 kilometres to
get down here to see this incredible
bird the Egyptian vulture a smart bird
as well as I said known to use tools
dropping rocks into nests bigger marrow
bones that they aren't able to break up
and get to mera they'll actually fly up
with them like the bearded vulture also
does that find some big boulders or
whatnot and will drop the the Mara bones
onto the boulders from quite a height to
break it open yeah I can't help myself
and this is the closest I've ever been
to an Egyptian vulture giving himself a
little bit of a preen but look at things
incredible
so very very distinct and quite
difficult to get them confused with
other vulture species such as a hooded
vulture and a juvenile hood we'll have a
brown cap all the way over and and the
other one and the adults will have a
white cap the whole way over there isn't
anything else really like the Egyptian
vulture and they their beak is so fine
in comparison to the other vulture
species and they lack that cap so as
they're saying the hooded vulture is the
only one you might maybe get confused
with but um only if you if if you don't
know your Birds and because this is a
this is a big one there are many many
birds who would be very very excited to
you to see this okay well I'm gonna
spend a little bit of quality time with
his Egyptian vulture before I go look
for some big cats in the meantime let's
send you to tailor ant in Ghana
well hats we're navigating around as you
can see we're having a bit of a chuckle
because Hasan has had his guard dog
watching the kill well just the chit
will reposition again but it's quite a
nice scene that we've got because we've
got ten Ghana we've got the hyena and
then of course that Impala which is
dangling in the trees so there we go
there's the old man who we've been
sitting with there's his guard dog it's
not really his guard dog everybody I'm
being just being silly
it is the hyena that we saw earlier that
was laying flat and then of course
there's the Impala just jangling away
now I don't know what he there we go
hang on it looks like he's about to
climb up the tree watch our Johnny is
too we've been watching Hassan ik time
of treason well I don't think he's
particularly good he hasn't quite worked
it out just yet he really does struggle
the way he tries to it's like he the way
that a fireman would shimmy down a pole
or a letter
hosana seems to try their technique
going up which in my opinion
all the observations that I had again
I'm no expert because I'm not a leopard
doesn't seem to work very well but let's
see here we go it's in Ghana does it
with absolute ease so I know it's not a
great view at the moment I will
reposition around in a little bit but I
thought it'd be quite nice to watch as
he climbed up that timber tea tree which
is where that Impala is hanging lots of
timber tea trees around here and now
this could get very exciting because
their carcass has been here for a couple
of days it's been decaying there's not
much left of it some scraps could quite
easily fall to the ground and that's
what that hyena is waiting for and if
you do know which I inna this is awesome
let us know hashtag safari life because
we are lucky and she sees the same
hyenas over and over again for example
example we saw ribbon and in Timur
in the video with the tiny versus horse
on a sighting Ruben was the one that
leaped up and tried to bite us on his
bottom all did in fact bite or sanas
bottom or here comes another hyena look
look look
this is exciting say we go to hyenas
these might be the hyenas I had on foot
the other day Oh No maybe it is a triple
an Tina I don't know maybe I'm not very
good at telling the difference anyways
they're waiting there for the scraps and
I think Jen garner might drop a bit now
a while Jim yes I think that Singhania
has the possibility of mating again most
certainly so I think one once
Tandi comes into East hrus and he'll be
the first to mate with her and any other
female leopards within the area or there
are any stress will probably seek out
someone lighting on her
they're not gonna be interested in
husana he's too young
there's obviously bigger stronger males
and we talk about this often the female
animals our chair won't want the best
genetics so they're not typically unless
they have to they're not going to meet
with a young inexperienced leopard
they'll probably mate with one of the
bigger boys and if jaghana disappears
though then it's fair game if he goes
away and he moves too far art untundi
might not want to venture too far away
then maybe Hassan is going to be the
next option even though they are related
but something we must remember Archer is
that sort of breeding with your brothers
and sisters is quite normal and it
hhor-- doesn't allow for it to happen
over to meet generations so typically
the male's will move art he he grabbed
something he didn't quite like they
thought it was gonna drop to the floor
and then it'll be like somebody dropping
some meat or something fruit or anything
into water where there's lots of catfish
or lots of piranhas and as hyenas are
gonna race on in but it does look like
he's struggling there to pull chunks of
flesh out there's not much left
wonderful well this has been a superb
sighting I'm thoroughly enjoying it
we're gonna continue sitting here and
watching the King eat David however has
found one of the smaller scavengers in
the Mara huge leopard that he respects
in Juma and to a smaller predator like
Jaco here we go to the black-backed
jackal
just laying on the road normally Jack
hoes go in pairs I'm surprised he is
alone and maybe he's watching the
beautiful sunset all the way in the Mara
triangle look at those beautiful eyes of
the sunsets how magnificent that is the
misty like smoke like background or the
backdrop of the older US government and
the wildebeest in the foreground and all
the Torchwood trees
what a beautiful wilderness me and man
walks in money to enjoy working here and
man who says when the fool and Nick the
fenachrone control says just beautiful
and normally the area we are as he
called it for those who've never joined
us before we are in Kenya in the Mara
triangle and we see the game is halfway
in Connemara triangle because our three
humps
one arm is the boundary between Kenya
and Tanzania the country's south of
Kenya and there's the Mara River for
those who are watching where we are
watching some epic moments and then the
other arm of the triangle is that
escapement you see there and that is cut
meant is called the Euler escapement in
that particular area the Alliance that
like hanging around that area and
there's one particular pride alliance
that we call the Oh Lala's
I found the owner of pride in Luxan
right below the escapement after which
they are named when an elephant appeared
any of the lionesses they looked up in
interest but relaxed again quickly the
elephant continued to eat in peace while
the pride enjoyed the cool of the marsh
grass and shade from the nearby quadrant
thickets lions around or here in the
Mara triangle excuse me
the owner operative Lions it is the
largest when all together they form a
strong 14 in number and that's a very
huge pride by any standard and that's
why you'd see even if an elephant or
just walking through them they'll just
look at the elephant and like what are
you up to
and they get curious just in case
because they know elephants are large
and once know how elephants will harass
them and then as you just saw there they
just ignore them and just carry on
enjoying their lives so all our loss is
one of the largest pride of lions we got
around here and it's time to move if
you're lucky we might be seeing them
again today but my current plan now is
to go look for some highness just cooled
off we started with some very warm
temperatures of about 20 80 degrees or
82 degrees Fahrenheit I think now we
have gone that we could be in low 20s
now all those 70s Fahrenheit at the
moment when the cools off most of the
animals get to be more active and hyenas
are not exception
and the tonally highness Veritas that
you'll always get busy or in the cold
soft but also other predators like
leopards get into action
we are still here with our sauna now
astana is now on the ground as I think
he was not comfortable high up by the
tree due to the stomach which is full
full at the moment and I can see these
some Impala that has been here down to
the water hole is just showing some
interest but you can see that is not
gonna it would be just a waste of time
he's not gonna win any better now
because he is so very heavy at the
moment so you can see is concentrating
on something I think this another
vehicle coming to join me here so you
can see that if you use these cats as a
monitor they will show you what is
happening every time I just have to look
at the eyes in the ears and that is what
is gonna tell me what's happening in the
surrounding interesting the beautiful
necklace is now showing clearly
you can see that with the reflection of
the Sun this is beautiful so the young
male leopards they have got to grow
older than 22 month is when they are
starting to show some interest but not
interacting with the females at that
stage but when they're about four years
or above four years that is when you
will see them fully participating and
trying to display the strength to
establish their own families
so you can see now that ice laying down
flat he just doesn't care
arrives on the ground on the road it's
not worried about the scent
maybe this turn helps he may not have
get rid of the parasite because earlier
on he was just rolling there and with
their legs open you can see those pores
so when the clouds are hiding in there
you will never think that this cats can
be able to climb victories it is this
hind legs which are there in order to
support him when he is climbing up these
cats are very much powerful and their
paws the the length can go up to a 60 80
to 100 millimeters and wide the poor can
go up to 60 to 80 millimeters so that's
quite a very big pour so what we are
seeing now is what we normally see on
the ground and if we can be able to
watch closely and identify some of the
cracks in between those kind of loops
there and the toes that can also make it
much much more easier for the
identification of this leopard when
seeing the tracks on the ground
we can see that now he's trying to rest
what is in the stomach
the ArrayList Kurt I have seen is the
caracal and the last time I've seen the
caracal it was long time ago so those
are one of the beautiful Cadillac the
AES you see there is pointing like this
and there can be really much aggressive
as well so the rarest cat I have seen it
was the CARICOM and I'm also hoping to
see the Caracara here in Duma
so you can see that this cat is now
laying down facing the you can see that
is now facing downhill after eating
quite a lot of Millie's facing downhill
I think that might be difficult in the
stomach maybe he's got an adaptation to
be able to block the what is in the
stomach from coming down the mouth but
now let's go to the Masai Mara where'd
of it is also looking for something
interesting at the moment the volu a
good but this time quite far away but
we've got a beautiful sunset we will
show you there that tree right in the
distance that one there it is oh my
goodness what an exciting Drive we made
it go start looking for some big cats
James I have you got the beautiful
sunset so we're gonna head back towards
where's the closest road from here that
way all that way that way is gonna be
the closest road this is a old road yeah
someone got stuck yet hold on I'm great
this way back to the vada Barra oh yeah
we're gonna go this way
oh the big bumps
ah so well then Susie indeed I
completely forgot I was yammering on
about all sorts of modern stuff about
them from but indeed there are the bird
that is most commonly seen in ancient
Egyptian hieroglyphics
well done Susie I completely forgot
about that now
thinking about it because historically
before we became a lot more tidy and
stuff Egyptian vultures were scavengers
or of around human habitation and
abattoirs and stuff like that so you
would probably find that the Egyptian
vultures would have spent a lot of time
around human habitation in ancient Egypt
so hence the fact that they are quite
common in in hieroglyphics didn't manage
to get the best photos of it but I've
still seen an Egyptian vulture that is a
big one for me I've been close once or
twice before once in the Serengeti eel
12 years ago Oh
Nicola wants to see a picture as I said
there weren't the best pictures I
haven't even looked at all of them yet
but because it's just the worst time of
the day that one's not too shabby and
that was just after it took off right I
know wrong wrong wheel I'm so excited
obviously no one's not too shabby
difficult in this in this low-light let
me just see as we find another one
quickly jams I didn't like to sit too
much Oh Nikki your comms are breaking up
sorry what awesome yeah I'm gonna have
to look at them properly I think I think
this one is going to be my my favorite I
saw it briefly but I haven't had a
chance to look at it where is it now
flying into the sunset
lots of decent silhouettes there I see
if we got one of it flying into the
sunset
there we go getting there don't suppose
for me it's going to be a very special
picture not the greatest photograph that
I've seen but sort of coming to the
sunset of my time in Kenya and there we
have the Egyptian vulture flying into
the sunset in focus okay I'm gonna keep
moving back to the main road maybe try
to find a cat or two before the end of
Drive in the meantime let's send you
back to the Juke of jummah with Madame
Acadie
and there he is
if he's not careful he's going to lose
that kill but luckily he's got one poor
holding on tight as he tries to stripped
the last of that Impala he's done well
he's pretty much eaten the entire
carcass which is awesome to see suppose
he has to hold on to them but he's got a
very very full belly in you know what if
he doesn't catch anything else with a
nice day or two I don't think it'll be a
trade smash I think he'll be fine so
give him a chance to just reinstate his
territory a game because while he's been
on this kill he's been very quiet and
hidden away not vocalizing as much so I
think it's important that he does go on
their territorial patroller game just to
remind everybody that he is still yeah
but again I can't myself very very lucky
to be out here this afternoon with all
these wonderful animals because well as
you know it's not just Ching Ghana we've
also got and their hyenas and they've
had a couple of mouthfuls because a few
scraps a few bones and things here and
they have dropped down onto the floor
and they've raced on in to try and grab
them but let's see look how they look
keep looking at that's one of my
favorite things the way that they glance
up it's almost like they're looking at
in Ghana with admiration but of course
this is not the case they just want a
scrap of food Nanci boo boo I've never
feasted upon an Impala a carcass that's
been up in the tree for a couple of days
so I wouldn't be the best person to ask
if the carcass will be easier to eat
after a few days hmmm I imagine that
it's the meat is becoming quite sort of
tender as it rots away in the Sun so
perhaps yes perhaps it is easier to tear
off of the bone as it's matured quite
nicely now for the last few days but
again I don't think I'll ever know the
answer to that because the day that I
start eating meat off of a carcass I
probably need to reconsider my life
choices
it's
let's hope it doesn't get to that but
this actually he's making good way I
mean that Impala neck has definitely got
quite a bit of flesh on it and an Impala
you forwards in Ghana is a great meal I
mean now you've seen he's eaten that for
the past couple of days and he's I was
wrong I mean I said I didn't oh there
goes a scrap of food let's see if
they're gonna squab love it no no
fighting
very civilized well done hyena well done
normally they always fight over it still
just looking at though they're going is
that all peace sir can I have some more
maybe what some of them are saying who
knows I actually don't know what fell
from the Chi cause it didn't look like
any of them ate anything mmm I suppose
hyenas do Hoover down there food if you
weren't watching and be easy to miss I'm
waiting for that bone to fall that's
dangling and then they said the hyenas
are looking at you I mean it's literally
hanging on by a thread and I can't
believe it hasn't dropped yet and Paula
you doesn't look too happy though sorry
that was terrible that was a very nice
sorry Impala thank you so much for
contributing to the circle of life and
of course it is important there are so
many impala de castilla walk antelope
species out there and that that's
exactly it at times like this it becomes
easier for lepers to take down prey
because they've got much to hide behind
I wish she would get to the neck though
because there he'd found lots of chunks
of flesh and he wouldn't have to very
delicately try and eat around the bones
which of course is going to be I think
is going to be his downfall is that he's
going to pull on the carcass and it's
going to completely fall in half and
he's going to be left with the bony bits
with a couple of scraps of meat and the
hyenas are gonna end up with a head and
the neck of the Impala which like I said
is filled with flesh them all though
infested with flies I'm sure there'd be
maggots and things did
inside Andy yes hyena poo is indeed
really white except when they defecate
it doesn't come out that color so it's
normally like a greeny
well quite lime-green that's the wrong
color and but there's definitely a green
sort of tinge to it perhaps if you've
ever seen your dogs defecate after
they've eaten a bone and then as it
dries out it's evident that there is a
substantial amount of calcium carbonate
so that's what makes the feces white is
it's all that excess calcium carbonate
from all the bones that they've been
feeding on but it takes a couple of days
to dry that color it would be quite
bizarre they defecated out white white
feces and I'd be concerned but Tigana
also relieved himself just before
climbing up the tree lightening the load
I can't wait for this carcass to fall to
the fall because there's three hyenas
now although we can only see two but
there are three around and who knows if
they do start to squabble over the
bigger scraps of meat then more might
follow
and speaking of hyenas of course they
seem to be around
Jumma quite a bit but the stars of the
show are the North clan in the Mara and
David has finally arrived at the den
well done Taylor with hyenas but I think
I got more serious hyenas than Taylor in
South Africa the only difference he's
ting ghana is up a tree well I don't
have eleven here now we have come to the
den of the north clan of highness and
what you go to the screen there this is
the leader of the North clan and her
name is waffles this is the community
for the North clan and apparently in
general hyenas are very clean animals
and they'll always make sure they do not
pull by the den
hyenas are known to scavenge but at
times they also hunt but more from the
north when they hunt
so Kant coming up there I'm not sure
this is one of the granddaughters of
waffles and there's a cab coming up out
there
hyenas people have mistaken them not to
be very good hunters and they always
scavenge but it surprised us we can see
a baby cub coming up there hyenas will
hunt on their own and more often than
not they'll always go for the easiest
prey to get down we heard the
heart-wrenching sound of a bull beast in
distress right next to the road in the
heart of North clan territory on closer
inspection we saw a North clan head pop
up over the long grass the mournful
wails of the world beast continued and
attracted a few more clan members
however with the migration camping about
in clan lands there was little fighting
over food the poor volu beast eventually
died after 28 minutes of being eaten
alive we got to the north clan den and
I'm not sure who this is but to the
ropes there's one of the cab's
looking do you want to come out and I
guess this should be one of the caps of
waffles
hello are you trying to sniff there
please come out and say hello to to us
do you want to bite that piece of grass
or he was just enjoying the wind see how
she blends in there she's all duck and
that's very typical of Cubs of hina caps
on the bone deer or black in color
sports don't show up until they're about
three months or so very good try and
come out
we got waffles on the right and I guess
that could be one of her cubs and hyenas
have been mistaken not to be very good
hunters but they do a very good job
but always with a choice they go for the
easiest prey to bring down
uh-uh the village a come from
I know hyenas have attacked people but
they'll only attack you if you get into
the away or if they have young cubs like
this if you happen to be close to the
den by mistake they would easily attack
people I might keep my voice bit softer
now and maybe that will encourage that
cab to keep coming out much closer and
you might be like to see more of it so
if you come on the way of the Highness
yes they might attack you but in general
we don't have lots of conflict of hyenas
and human beings as it is for example
with hippos and human beings always
buffaloes and human beings
look at that cub or are there she is
trying to either get mama into play and
I doubt that his wife was cub because
she seems to be very bonded to that
female there and I'm saying because the
female because of her size but my
initial guess it was waffles cub I'm not
sure for a fact because waffles Cubs are
about six weeks old or thereabouts she
got two but every time we come to his
den one of them is more playful than the
other
Jemma that's a great question I will not
say I can remember for now how many
litres they'd have in their lifetime but
out guess them living for about 12 years
in the world 12 years gas station burger
three and a half months or thereabout I
would say I would not be surprised if
they'd have about 10 liters in their
life and the loaders have one to four
cups okay let me have to be a bit soft
here just to make sure this cab get the
courage to be out what force got two
cabs so a liter of - it's very normal
so Gemma I'll be finding out for you how
many litres a female hyena can have in
his life but again it would vary from
one high net to the other or from one
species to the other what we go to the
screen now these are what we call a
spotted hyenas or crocotta crocotta so
there should be another cap somewhere in
that den so she is getting the courage
to slowly come out
Merson i'm andras out think so and Jamie
when she led before she went for leave
she got teddy bear would be having Cubs
and it's very possible it's very
possible we are just waiting maybe you
might get surprised and I'll tell you
what mr. Murray we don't miss to visit
this then ideally if not twice in a day
every dowon's personally now I'm getting
a lot of interest with hyenas so just
stay on the lookout and once we know the
good Cubs will you know give you the
notification but your teddy bear might
be having Cubs any time soon so I'm just
wondering whether this is soup or not
not very sure this hyena is very sleepy
and the cub is just trying Eider to nuts
or play with the momma and we'll just
stay here waiting for the other cab to
come out and as designer continue
sleeping I think there's another
predator that is also sleepy in South
Africa I have got the sleeping or sauna
here you can see now his resting
position his is just sleeping there with
the legs open and I think that is very
good for him in order to get rid of the
parasites because the dogs and cats when
having quite a lot of parasites you see
them opening their legs and exposing
themselves to the Sun so but here I'm
sure he's helping him with that but also
in order to arrange too much food which
is in the stomach at the moment I saw
not long time ago
he also excreted he just left the
droppings here and I can see where those
droppings are I was very lucky because
the wind was not blowing towards my
direction so the wind was blowing to the
other side I know the droppings for
these cats specifically the first meal
after a kill it doesn't smell nice
Rosina if a new female leopard comes to
hosana
at this stage he might try maybe to
convince the female in order to start
the relationship but I can promise you
at this stage is not yet worried about
the activities mating activities with
the females I think the level of
testosterone is not yet day-o I can see
a deck are going to drink again down
there at the waterhole at the moment
which is not very far away from where we
are you can see there there's a dead
girl slowly approaching
so this cat might catch he might catch
another prey I can promise you or Zhanna
is not trustworthy
specifically when is around davia
Telepan here is where he's doing quite a
lot of predation activities the most
Wendy asana like any other cats when
they are less than seven to eight years
they will see the nose is going to stay
pink but soon as they get seven to eight
years is then that the tip of the nose
and the color of the north is going to
change completely and become stuck yes
you are correct as they are getting old
is when the darkness is going to shade
that nose
you can see it seems like it's dreaming
so now let's go to a tailor who's got
Tenggara at the moment in see if the
highness are still there designers don't
want to give up look at the snow they're
persistent creatures hey Sydney and
that's why I love them look look odd hey
guys the kill sorry 10 gone I know I'm
laughing at you but you had that coming
my friend and there's the hyena now with
it very very chuffed the other hyenas
have all run off because they grabbed a
mouthful themselves are you going to go
with it now oh here we go it's good now
that they've realized that this is the
hi you know that's got the kill they're
probably going to chase it dragging it
away quickly
how great is that audio we're gonna see
if we can't get more incredible audio go
on go and fight that how you know now
let's see what else happens that's what
we've been waiting for the entire
afternoon is the Chitti for this to
happen and finally it did our patience
paid off there we go that's what Tanana
should have been eating not quite the
bones
Philippa doesn't have strong enough jaws
to crunch through that but it's going to
try its space ah
thank you Chris rogue it's great to hear
from you again you said that this is
heart this is the name of the hyena and
heart is a girl
I'm assuming got the prize just nibbling
down on it now we're not nibbling down
sorry that implies it is eating it quite
nicely that's of course not the case
knew that very easy to pull straight
through it and hyenas will eat every
single part of a carcass whereas
somebody liked in Ghana there's not
particularly worried about eating all
the bones or even the hide there goes
husana now he's coming down he's got a
mouthful of something some part I think
like I said a bony butt or the few
scraps and I was going to eat vertically
you better be careful husana those
hyenas iron jumping distance and they
could snatch your tail if you dangle it
down but he's been very careful to loop
it over the top of the branch which i
think is actually very clever perhaps he
also watched the video on husana getting
nipped on the bum
or perhaps it's just first-hand
experience most likely first-hand
experience of course but that is
incredible to see if I put some lights a
little bit of lighting you know it's a
little bit better and actually is quite
eerie now but the base of the tree lit
well of course I can put spotlights on
hyenas and and fully grown leopards they
don't mind it whatsoever it just looks
beautiful
you Wow I think Osan is just I mean
honest honest in Ghana sorry I don't why
I'm saying her son nah singhania's she's
going to stay there and I think finish
up what's left and then I reckon you'll
come down the tree and go off on his
damn right off you go
to a clan that's far superior than the
Juma clan because there's many more
members and their incredible hunters but
of course they're so cute
teyla don't go in our Tara stay there
because it's quite dramatic when you see
leopards and hyenas notching each other
food and the cub is trying to come out
there us the mother is just laying
sleepy I hope I do not wake you up
you're trying to keep my voice as low as
possible we have come back this evening
to the north plan I understand and have
been very lucky to see waffles and
waffles is the matric or the leader of
this clan at school in Ithaca and that
is the den where we have one of the
females laying down and with the cabbage
trying to come out there hyenas have
been mistaken to be scavengers but when
possible
hyenas also hunt for themselves and what
they do they usually go for the easily
or easily available prey
we arrived at to the north clans home in
a den in the evening to find waffles
eating dinner fearlessly protective over
her meal she brought it to the mouth of
the barrel but no Cubs came out we
revisited the den the next day and we
were in luck the Cubs came out of the
barrel exploring the outside world with
more confidence they treated us to the
sight of them playing with each other
nothing there mum before settling down
for the rest of the afternoon there's
nothing as good as seeing higher cubs
playing chasing each other which is very
typical of all carnival youngsters
because they like to build their muscles
and they have always known or the
trained running is very important just
like you know we human beings when we
say we have a happy I want to do
something also the hina crabs have what
we call the social hours which are
always normally early in the morning and
late in the evening so seeing two of
them which were two Cubs that belong to
ruffles running and kissing each other
it was quite epic so we just sting here
at the den and one of them has been
coming out and going back out and going
back and not the other a couple of days
ago me and Manu we were debating how
come one is more active or more playful
than the other and man who said and that
was a boy and I said that was a girl I
forgot to give a poll to the viewers
that they asking them what they thought
man why you still standing without did
he change your mind yeah man who changed
his mind and he agreed with me that boys
will be boys so chances are the one that
has always been coming out or what we've
been seing even today chances are it is
a male but I'll tell you not even Cubs
even four fully grown hyenas it is very
difficult to tell their sex is almost
impossible you need to spend so much
time with them and what will happen is
unless you see them out in the field and
maybe you see under the bellies and
you're lucky to see the mammary glands
that's the only time you can tell a male
from a female otherwise from a distance
it's difficult in size in general
females are little bigger than males and
that's only where you can tell them
apart otherwise should you look on the
genitalia or the real product
reproductive organs sorry females also
have what we call upset oh you know
pennies and you might mistake that to be
I mean you try to see what a work force
can wake up their mono but she just put
her head up now and she isn't interested
in moving she doesn't even want to call
the cabs and I'm trying to imagine at
one point she you know might want or
encourage the cubs to come out well
darkness is coming where we are in the
Masai Mara Triangle in Kenya and we want
to thank you very much for having joined
us remember we'll be out here again
tomorrow morning and on behalf of the
magic cameraman Manu and myself we all
have to say goodbye and have a very good
one
from the beautiful Masai Mara right well
heart is not sharing with anybody I saw
I'm uncertain as to who that other two
hyenas where I'm gonna go ahead and are
they ribbon and Timur I'm not sure I
really am Not sure but here they are
instead sunlight here hmm and I was I
think I did ask you guys all a little
bit earlier and I'm sure someone would
have got back to me like I said I'm not
particularly good when it comes to
identifying hyenas and who they are and
what their business is all I know is
that hard seems to be a little bit more
high-ranking I've got nothing for you
another saying is like well
do you have any scraps nope you won't
believe how massive these hyenas heads
really are I mean they don't look like
particularly big creatures but they
really are they're much bigger than
leopards I mean in terms of weight maybe
10 Ghana will be a bit bit heavier than
some of these hyenas difficult to say
nice little stretch there Oh fantastic
but it has been a special afternoon
we've seen all sorts of wonderful things
look at this one having her own around
in the in the sand now Jamie I know I
don't think Kangana is the biggest male
leopard he might be here on Juma but
remember and leopards can move around
they can roam the biggest leopard I
haven't seen him yet in in the sabi sand
is a leopard by the name of the Andersen
male and he hangs around a little bit
further west from here I'm sure at some
point along taganas journey in life he
would have met the Andersen male and you
know will be incredible to see the two
of them together so I don't think tan
ganas anywhere near his size though
although he is big he's really not a
small cat and leopards are incredibly
powerful animals even for their size I
mean they can carry an entire carcass of
a tree hey hey you know you having just
the best time ever so not only do birds
like to dust baths and zebra but
apparently hyenas do too and it's been a
successful day for these hyenas they've
had a little bit to eat maybe not this
one so much I think is trying to get rid
of a scratch too as its doing a little
bit of a bottom wiggle thank you so much
for the entertainment animals you've all
been spectacular you've done your job
today and more not going to have a rotor
on it but thank you very much for
joining us and join us tomorrow for the
sunrise Safari and we look forward to
chatting to you then